when you pay that first month rent and
security deposit
first month rent fine you're paying your
rent the security deposit
fourteen hundred dollars just gets put
into an escrow account
that by law you can't use the landlord
can't touch
it's just dead money sitting there and
yet most americans don't have 500
for an emergency expense when you rent
anything else andrew
you don't put up the cash you don't give
herds 10 000
in case you get into an accident why
can't that same model apply
to housing right instead of paying a
thousand dollars of a cash deposit
why can't you just opt if you want say
i'd rather sign up for five dollars a
month
and have insurance that covers the
landlord so i don't have to put that
money up and i'm not sitting there
if you're if you are in government and
you hear this you're like well this is a
win because like you know just more more
money in people's pockets more money
presumably gets spent more money and
emergency savings to earlier point
most policies have a win-lose type model
right in fact that's by the way the
first concern most political folks who
talk to us
think about is well it must be a win
lose right landlord must be losing
who's going to be here and who's unions
going to call me and whose lobby's going
to call me and who's going to get mad at
me for
for something like this right but like
you and i know this from the private
sector
you have to create win-win solutions in
order for a business to work
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks this is your
co-host zach grauman
on today's episode encore jane
joined the podcast to speak with andrew
guys
encore is a fascinating human being
inc magazine once called him the best
connected
21 year old in the world and that was a
while ago he
think he's in his uh he's older than
that now he was vp of product at tinder
so if you ever got a tinder date off of
that app you can thank him directly
but also what he's working on now is
running a venture fund that's investing
in companies that are helping young
people
basically solve problems that our
government should be solving so he is
working on a startup that is eliminating
the security deposit when you rent an
apartment
he's working on a credit card that you
can build up points
when you pay rent there's incredible
stuff this guy's working on you've got
two entrepreneurs him and andrew
have this perspective um and
conversation that
one we need to have but two is
fascinating to listen to so you're going
to enjoy it the other thing i want to
let you guys know
in celebration of our 100th episode
woohoo
we are going to do an ask
yang speaks episode basically a mailbag
episode so if you go on twitter and use
the hashtag
ask yang speaks let us know your
questions
we will try to answer as many of them as
we can keep them fun keep them
substitutive we will do
some serious ones i'll try to do rapid
fire but i want to be a real
conversation as well so tbd on that
that'll be our 100th episode
celebration but for now encore jane
two titans of entrepreneurship um some
really fascinating people
between him and andrew you have this
great conversation so enjoy it
on yang speaks right now
[Music]
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to welcome to yang
speaks the founder and ceo of kairos one
of
to me the most cutting edge investors
and
entrepreneurs uh in in really the
industry today encore jane welcome
encore
hey it's good to be here andrew it's
kind of you know it's funny being here
on this podcast with you after like
i think the last time we talked when i
was not even out of college yet it's
been a
hell of a run for you since then yeah
the last time we spoke was about
10 years ago you were the
one of the heads of something called a
cairo society i want to say that
was this massive network for
budding entrepreneurs at the college
level and i have to say because of you
uh like the the folks in cairo was wound
up with all sorts of like incredible
exposure and experiences i remember
being really impressed i was like holy
cow how the heck they make this happen
in college
[Laughter]
it was a it was a really unique time i
mean it was right we started that
back in 2008 and if you remember this is
the original
uh kind of financial crisis right 2008
all the banks collapsed
and what's wild is it back then if you
said you were an entrepreneur
it just meant that you were unemployable
if you didn't get a job at a bank or
consulting firm
i mean that's when you became an
entrepreneur and then all of a sudden
all the banks
and consulting companies kind of went
went under in 2008
and the opportunity cost for really
really smart
talent to take on some of the big
challenges facing the world
went away and so now great talent coming
out of these universities could say well
what if i spent the next two years
trying to build a business
that solves healthcare that takes on
clean energy that takes on
issues in housing or any of these areas
of focus
i think a lot of our entrepreneurs got
involved with venture for america back
in the day
oh yeah we had like this kind of
synergistic uh
relationship um where a lot of the folks
who were
applying to venture for america at the
time would have kairos on their
resumes uh you know or essays or what
have you
and we you'll be happy to know we always
took that as
uh a big plus because we're like ooh
this person's definitely aligned because
they've been hustling in this direction
so so yeah you should know there was
always like this kind of shared dna
i thought and it's incredible to see you
as well
the this number of years later and
everything you've done i guess from your
perspective too you'd be like holy cow
that andrew yang i ended up like
running for president and doing all
sorts of stuff i mean it's just great it
was so inspiring for me to see
someone that was so passionate about
entrepreneurship and the idea of
creating value in the world
run for office i mean that's just you
know most of us aren't brave enough to
take on that kind of challenge and
uh put ourselves out there in that way
but it's god the world needs something
like that i'm telling you it's
creative thinking innovative thinking
look at this encore's gonna throw his
hat in the ring
and run for office dude um so encore one
of the the reasons why i think that you
had such an elevated perspective is
you know your father is a very very
successful entrepreneur so i think you
hit the ground running
that's something i wanted to to talk to
you a little bit about did you ever feel
like a sense of almost like greater
responsibility given that you're like
okay like my dad had done all of this
like i guess i'd better
like you know uh do something
significant honestly
so not that way but it was a interesting
i mean
were your parents that first generation
here andrew was it your parents
my parents they moved here as students
and then uh from from taiwan they met as
students
at uc berkeley got it so like i think
that's the part that inspires me the
most about
you know my parents story right my my
dad grew up in a
poor village in india right and
the idea of him getting a college degree
much less coming to the united states
much less helping to launch some of the
companies did it was
much less today like working on rocket
ships to the moon was like
literally crazy right and so
seeing how for him coming to this
country
gave him all those opportunities for
kind of a young boy from india coming
out of college getting an entry-level
job in the united states
and then working his way up into
creating real things like
that is something so special and that's
actually i think what drove me more than
saying
god i have shoes to fill is that if if
he could pull that
off coming from where he came from
what's the kind of impact
someone like you or i could make on the
world given the footing that we had
growing up being born in this country
um with this kind of opportunity and to
his credit
you know and to my mom and dad's credit
throughout my childhood
there was no in fact i think that the
indian
stick was still the leading leading
driver if there was no freebies no
giveaways if it was like
you know if you wanted to get something
and you asked your parent my parents for
you know allowance they would you know
they'd say sure i'll give you the money
to buy this but you can also pay for
your tuition then too
so that's a pretty good comeback while
you're at school
well i'll tell you it forces you as a
young kid to then find
creative ways to get what you want right
and that is the spirit of
entrepreneurship
right and so all of a sudden if you want
to buy something
you've got to find a way to get it as
part of some exchange and that's
literally what i how i started my first
company back when i was 12
was wanting to buy things and not being
able to use money so having to figure
out how to do some deal with these
companies
as a kid nice murdering young encores
exactly no but but i can relate to this
and
um when i was running for president i
sometimes reference the fact that it's
like you know my father grew up on a
peanut farm with no floor i remember
when i saw that farm too though it had
like had built a floor by the time i
visited in my teens but i was still like
holy cow man
like dad you grew up here i can't even
like
fathom that type of culture shock right
i mean i sometimes felt it going from
seattle to new york
right yeah i can't imagine going from
you know a farm in
taiwan or my dad's village in india to
this
world right yeah so seeing my dad
transition
uh though i didn't see it i mean i kind
of figured it out after the fact but i
agree with you it kind of lights a fire
under you whether you're like okay
i'd better you know i mean also
both of our parents like they they
fought through this to create
opportunity and a platform for
us and i i think you know one of the
things my
parents have always talked about has
been you can't really when you come from
that back and you realize
you can't really measure success by how
much money you've made but you start to
measure it by
how many lives you impact right yeah
hey man well look the nice thing about
this and this is
the core adventure for america core of
what the original kairos was and what it
is today is that
when you really think about it from that
perspective it's
actually the key to also making money
right it's that if you can solve a big
enough problem that
impacts a lot of lives it also then
leads
to financial success right and i think
that middle point has sometimes gotten
lost in silicon valley where people just
chase
the next crypto this or vr that or
platform this without
actually thinking about what problem
they're solving
or the impact it can have on someone's
life that they're willing to
pay for it right i certainly love the
idea of impact as a measurement
and you know when i did decide to run
for president it was about like okay how
can i solve this problem at a large
enough scale
where uh you know we can actually start
to um
move society forward and make progress
um
and i love what you're saying it's like
look you know if you try and have a big
enough impact then the money will come
um that's certainly something that you
hoped is true
one of the big frustrations i have and
this is something that kairos is working
on
is that there's a lot of investment
capital available for people who are
trying to
solve certain types of problems and then
there are other types of problems where
it's like yeah
like i don't like i don't really need to
to invest in that
and so and you kind of know
unfortunately the latter category
are areas that tend to be most important
and impactful to your point um you know
like uh like chamatha talks about a
little bit of this with with his
um social capital you know fund where
uh like the easy money is being made in
this this very
active marketplace but then the longer
term problems around let's call it
climate change or
education or elder care or like whatever
it is
there's huge problems huge problems
they're getting worse and then in theory
you're like well the public sector
should address that
and then like we're kind of waiting for
the public sector to do it
right it's funny you say it so kairos is
a word when i
12 years ago was creating the original
talent incubator for entrepreneurs
it means the right moment in greek right
and so in 2008 when the world's
financial systems collapsed to me it was
the right moment
for young people to get out and try
entrepreneurship as a path
to creating their career and making an
impact right in 2017
after i was prior previously running
product for tinder after we sold that
company
uh so wait let's refine it for a second
because tinder's super famous you're
like running product to tinder so did
that involve going on a lot of dates
yourself
you know what i was uh prior to working
at tinder yes but
after that i was i was in a very happy
relationship during that time so
but made me very popular amongst my
friends who wanted special features
at tinder that didn't even exist but it
made a lot of phone calls coming in
i think what's so interesting is in 2017
right as you were thinking about
this kind of election and oh yeah man
that's what i had activated i was like
all right let's
let's try it was a moment it was a
moment in time and so that was actually
by the way
most people don't know this that's when
we bought the name cairo's back
for a new company i started because it
felt like the right moment in time again
and i'd say what's funny is you and i
kind of took slightly
different approaches but i said guys
technology companies in so many ways
have more power today to make change
than the government
right and unfortunately a lot of that
isn't being used for the good
and the solutions that you are
referencing uh to some of these problems
whether it's
again elder care or housing or health
care child care right
but there is an opportunity for that to
be the case
and so i do think and that's what we're
spending all of our efforts on is trying
to move capital away move
talent away from silly ideas frankly
that no one really needs
and raise billions of dollars into the
problems that
matter today and by the way to every
venture capitalist that i meet who says
they love to invest in
you know smart devices and blockchain
and this i say like
student loans is 1.3 trillion dollars
outstanding
right housing is hundreds of billions
500 billion
dollars a year spent on rent how much
money is spent on alexa power toasters
on a daily basis i have no idea
but from your market size mba quadrant
i'm betting that the big problems in the
world are
actually better investment opportunities
and if
the kind of work you're doing and the
work we're trying to do and others
starts to focus on that
and hopefully for like your kids and
maybe one day my kids
that is the example people look at when
they think of entrepreneurship
i love it and when when i was running
for president i'd go around the country
and there are three things that were
making everyone miserable
housing education and health care costs
like if you look around like the average
american
has seen their income more or less
stagnate and then those three things
housing education and healthcare just
keep going
going up in price and they're just like
oh what am i doing it's like making
everyone
crazy in my opinion
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you by better help
i love better help oh my gosh i do once
a week my therapist my her fake name
is sarah cause i don't wanna i don't
know still's wrong maybe tell her real
name because supposed to be
confidential with me but anyway it's
amazing i can go online i go and i
register i pick i can do video i can
chat i can shatter anytime
it's awesome you can start communicating
so fast like under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's just professional
counseling done securely online
so you can talk to your counselor i talk
to sarah all the time
it's fantastic you can get it all over
the world and you get licensed
professional counselors that
match with you depending on what you're
looking for whether you're coping with
depression or stress
anxiety relationships grief self-esteem
for me it's just like i need help with
figuring out the direction of the world
navigating what is going on out there we
try to do that on the pod
but better help is there too i really
really can't stress
enough how important it is to get your
thoughts emotions out there to talk to
somebody it's great so here's the deal
and once you start living a happier life
today and as a listener of yank speaks
you'll get 10 off your first month by
visiting our sponsor
betterhelp.com yang join over one
million people have taken charge of
their mental health
like me and andrew we got this that's
betterhelphelp.com
yang
[Music]
so you've been working on some of these
problems and i i can't wait
uh to dig into some of the ways that
you're trying to improve
uh one of these big massive parts of the
economy uh where do you want like
which one you want to tackle first i
mean look i i always
it's funny the way we approached this we
said what is the single largest expense
that most americans deal with every
single month
and it's housing right and when you
think about
rent which is even a kind of subset of
housing
what's crazy is that rent prices
keep going up and yet the quality of
housing is going
down what other market in the world
do people pay more and more and more and
get less and less
right you went from like a home to a
floor
to an apartment to like a new york
shoebox you know
for even more money and that to me
spells problem which spells opportunity
right and so when we started looking at
the housing market
obviously everyone talks about the
monthly rent cost
right but what we often forget are the
things that we take most for granted
which when it came to housing was the
upfront cost it takes to just move into
an apartment
back in 2000 and i was going to date
myself or whatever it's like 2002.
um so this was like the the
bubble bursting before the the financial
crisis you're talking about
so i moved into a new york city
apartment i was young i was in my 20s
and because it was a very very difficult
economic climate
they were offering two free months on a
one year lease
and i moved in with a friend of mine and
so we had to pay one month
up front and a deposit i believe
but then because we paid for the first
month and we're getting two months free
we didn't have to pay rent for three
months
and and it was like the greatest three
months of our lives
like imagine being a 20 something year
old and not paying rent for a few months
and still living in an apartment like
not with your parents or whatever
so so we were just like so happy me and
my roommate
uh a guy named andy george uh that i
grew up with
so the two of us were living in this
apartment and then when they started
charging us rent
um in month four we were so sad we were
like don't live here for a break
because like you've been in there for
three months without paying rent that's
probably the last time that people had
that experience up until this last year
right and i'll say like
one of the stories that i've heard one
of the few like
i guess silver linings of some of the
current
tough situation the world has gone
through is people had a chance
to go back and you know they didn't have
to be in the main city
next to their job for the last 12 months
and so a lot of people had a chance to
move back in with their family or
move in with friends and save a lot of
money on rent that they were at
where which i think actually has saved
millions of americans throughout this
economic crisis which is the amount of
money they were saving on rent
is what gave them that cushion
unfortunately obviously not everyone
could do that but
for those who could it was a big deal so
you talked about first month rent
security deposit right
the average rent in new york city two
thousand dollars across the country
takes smaller places around the
countries almost fourteen hundred
dollars
okay when you pay that first month rent
and security deposit
first month rent fine you're paying your
rent the security deposit
fourteen hundred dollars just gets put
into an escrow account
that by law you can't use the landlord
can't touch
it's just dead money sitting there and
yet most americans don't have 500
for an emergency expense right so you've
got this weird thing where
every landlord is saying give me
thousands of dollars to put aside
you rich man and you're saying i don't
even have 500 for an emergency expense
what 1500
are you talking about um and so we
looked at that and said
wait a second that feels a little weird
and then you look a little deeper and
you realize that there's 45
billion dollars of cash sitting in
residential rental security deposits
wow generating no interest wow that
nobody can touch
and you're like wait a second something
here is wrong
right if we could just give that money
back i mean
think about the stimulus package
everyone's been talking about
we could give back 1400 to every rental
household in this country
without any of congress's approval just
by
unlocking security deposits right so
obviously
when you first asked the question well
why not just get rid of security deposit
well so so the per yeah the purpose of
the security deposit theoretically is
that if
i trash your place then i can uh use a
security deposit to pay for damages or
if i
don't pay rent i can apply the deposit
exactly
right so there is a purpose right it
protects landlords from
that kind of bad behavior abuse
the truth though is that if you look at
the data
it's a very small percentage of people
in the country who are bad renters like
that
we're talking about low single digits
right so here you have
a market where 45 billion dollars are
trapped away and most of it just sits
from one deposit count to another as you
move apartments
never to be used now when you rent
anything else andrew
you don't put up the cash right if you
were to rent a car from like hertz
you don't give her it's ten thousand
dollars in case you get into an accident
you give them your say 20 bucks a day
for the car and maybe five dollars a day
for the insurance
right why can't that same model apply
to housing right instead of paying a
thousand dollars of a cash deposit
why can't you just opt if you want to
say i'd rather sign up for five dollars
a month
and have insurance that covers the
landlord so i don't have to put that
money up and i'm not sitting there
so that was the simple idea that now
three years later
we drink covid using this program
we were able to give back a quarter
billion dollars
to renters across the united states you
got the deposits back
and replaced it with this low-cost
insurance landlord stayed protected
and a quarter billion dollars went back
into the pockets of americans
without changing the taxes or without
creating a new stimulus plan
just with that okay okay so let's run
through a scenario okay okay
hang on um so i i buy that
most renters are well behaved because
you know i've been a renter
and i always was like living in fear
somehow of like frankly screwing up in
some way it's like you know you just
like pay a rent and you know
like try and be a good tenant um so
so so let's say that 95 percent of
renters are
in this category um i show up to an
apartment
and then um let's say that we're using
two thousand dollars for ease
um like uh let's go back to my my uh 20
something-year-old case where it's like
me and my friend or both
20-something-year-olds um and each of us
like is gonna pay fifteen hundred
dollars a month in rent for a three
thousand dollar
um apartment so ordinarily we put up
three thousand dollars in a security
deposit
but in the new world how much are we
spending
on this low-cost insurance policy
and then if we do end up trashing the
place what does the landlord
get you have a choice when you move into
the apartment
you can either pay the two thousand
dollars of cash if you like which
most people prefer not to or you can pay
in that case would be about 10
a month for this insurance in this new
world i'm spending
10 bucks a month which is 120 a year and
then that's like in perpetuity which is
still
a deal like most anyone would take this
you put that you can take that money out
and put it in the market and generate
more than that ten dollars
a month on the average historical stock
market gains of seven percent so so for
the tenant this is a no-brainer i'm into
it and then
for the landlord like what did you get
if you end up
you know being a jerk the same full
coverage
of the security deposit right so if
there ends up being
kind of damage or non-payment of rent
things that would be
covered by a security deposit the
landlord who by the way also no longer
has to manage all this cash
handle a separate escrow account for
each resident
track the income from each resident and
move it into a you know when they cash
out
they now just they say those damages or
non-payment rent they file the claim
within 24 hours the money's in their
bank account
and the claim is over right and that's
that's something
that this company that you started now
handles or you invested in
uh is that right yeah co-founder of the
company yeah and so that's up and
running it's called
rhino but like across the country now
renters have that choice
if i'm a renter i want this immediately
because it's like this is vastly
superior to a security deposit
so if i show up to an apartment
and then they're like security deposit
please and then i'm like i would prefer
to use rhino and then the landlord is
like
what the hell is that like what what
does that step look like it's a process
right so in
most major hi we today as one company if
now many that have come into the space
but
we work with over a million apartments
across the united states
to provide this option to renters right
now so so do you sell to the landlords
and the apartment
uh holders or the renters so we partner
with the apartments
to then who then accept the policy in
place of a cash deposit
and then the resident can choose to sign
up and pay the monthly
five dollar ten dollar fee or pay the
cash deposit what's exciting
is that as this has had a lot of impact
across the country and again it's mostly
been with
kind of the more high-rise buildings
that you'll see in major cities
all of a sudden a lot of people from
your world right they like the mayors
and governors
both on republicans and democrat sides
started reaching out
to ask more about this right and the
idea was wait a second
could we accelerate something like this
to help make sure that
everyone has access to these options and
that money is going back into the
economy
um for my constituents oh yeah if you're
if you are in government and you hear
this you're like well this is a win
because like you know just more more
money in people's pockets more money
presumably gets spent more money in
emergency savings to earlier point
most policies have a win-lose type model
right in fact that's by the way the
first concern most political folks who
talk to us
think about it well it must be a win
lose right landlord must be losing
who's going to be right and who's
union's going to call me and whose
lobby's going to call me and who's going
to get mad at me for
for something like this right but like
you and i know this from the private
sector
you have to create win-win solutions in
order for a business to work
so the name of this uh category is
security deposit replacement is that
right security yeah security
we call it security deposit insurance
but it's a form of an alternative
to traditional cash deposits look i just
can't wait for the memes on reddit three
years from now when people are like
remember back in the day when you had to
hand over your life savings just to move
into an apartment
and it'll just be you know a thing of
the past our kids will have no
idea what that meant to have to put up
thousands of dollars
just to move into an apartment i love
this so much i mean like you said
you know you could get billions of
dollars back into people's hands
and it's a win-win this is genius rhino
is genius
i love rhino
[Music]
the world is opening up again we can go
outside again so whether you're working
or playing a lot of us can be on the
move this summer and my advice to you
take your raycon earbuds with you so a
pair of raikon
wireless earbuds in your ears make all
the difference in what you're doing when
we're finally getting outside this
summer you get crisp powerful beats
at half the price of all the other
premium audio brands
they look great they feel even better
and they come in a range of cool colors
so with customizable gel tips intended
for a comfortable
in-ear fit and they're built to go
wherever you go with a quick seamless
bluetooth pairing
and compact charging case it's pretty
freaking awesome
i could take them anywhere throw them in
my bag normal suitcase throw them in the
pocket so this is the deal
raycon's offering 15 off all their
products for our listeners and here's
what you've got to do to get it
go to buy raycon dot com slash yang
you'll get 15
off your entire recon order it's an
awesome deal you'll want to grab a pair
and a spare that's 15 off buy raycon.com
[Music]
[Applause]
you're working on something else in the
same space right that there's a wave to
tie
someone's credit card points also into
rental savings is that correct
so you're getting ahead of yourself
andrew but i'll tell you all about this
in june
um we are working on a
potentially crazy idea that will give
every renter in america a path to home
ownership
just by paying rent um at any apartment
building in the country
we are we're going to announce that in
june and i can't wait to tell you all
about it first
but oh well very exciting so
what other opportunities or
inefficiencies have you identified if
any
like that that are going to make people
go wow i mean so housing's the number
one area focus right
can we get rid of these costs to moving
in can we then give
every young person in this country a
path to homeownership and then obviously
the next big expense people deal with
is healthcare healthcare is interesting
because
the old model of healthcare has always
been
about bringing people into hospitals
bringing people as they get older
into nursing homes right and the
challenge with that is as we saw
unfortunately during this last
year is our systems are not set up to do
that
it is a really crappy experience for the
patients
and it's really unfortunate for like our
parents and grandparents as they age
that they just get thrown into these
nursing homes which if you're not lucky
enough to afford
one of the nicest ones most of these
nursing homes
have extraordinarily high loneliness
rates depression rates death rates abuse
rates i mean it's really
just it's messed up right and as you
know
over 50 percent of the or almost fifty
percent of the
uh death during covet happened at
nursing homes because of the
lack of safety protocols the spread etc
so three years ago as we were launching
rhino we thought
is there a new model of health care we
can build that moves care
out of hospitals out of nursing homes
into people's homes
right home care it's a market that has
been around for a long time
but it's not affordable it's not
technologically up-to-date
yeah most of this right now would
consist of a home health care aide that
comes and
um you know presumably spends time with
you which is
um expensive um even though the people
in that industry are systematically
underpaid and exploited just throwing
that out there
but despite that it's still very
expensive there is a lot of care that
requires
a home health aid type support there's
care that needs more specialized support
and then there's care that can be
provided digitally
right um and so we said how can we kind
of rethink that system starting with
our parents and grandparents who need
this help most right so the first thing
is to your point about home health aides
today part of the reason they're not
able to be paid well is because it's so
hard for these local businesses
to generate enough hours in the day that
they can optimize
they're only going in for three hours to
a client and then not earning any income
and they're not getting paid
to do their job right so
technology exists uber doordash these
businesses have built routing technology
to allow you to find
better ways to optimize kind of
routes and care right and so if we can
start to
give a worker a way to keep eight hours
a day
of continuous care they can now receive
real wages that actually allow them to
sustain their own life
livelihoods right that was number one
number two is that
you can't rely and expect any one person
to know everything about the health of
their
client like i don't want to trust my my
parents or my grandparents care
to some home health aide who's trying to
figure it out all of themselves
when there's so many factors there and
so we empower
each person with a with essentially a
smart app that
guides them through what to do and
identifies risk factors that the doctors
can get involved
when they need without having to wait
until something ends up in the hospital
right so we launched this uh actually
starting in london because
the nhs the government health care
system
contracted us to work with them on this
it's called sarah c-e-r-a
and what's exciting is we have been able
to both create
tens of thousands of jobs through this
program and provide
more affordable higher quality care
across the united kingdom so
during covid we're doing an average of
15 000
home visits a day um we helped the
government create over 20
000 jobs just during the first few
months as people were getting laid off
by retraining them what i'm hearing from
this is just
home health care aids like on demand
uh like that that can be um routed more
efficiently
than is currently possible that's what
i'm hearing is that that's correct well
i just wanna
i guess i want to clarify it's not on
demand right i mean you can do that if
you had an
emergency need but most care is
recurring
right so it is coming in three times a
week or
every day for daycare or coming in at
night for overnight care
or on a regular basis for more
specialized treatment like dialysis
treatment etc
right so it is scheduled out it just
requires
the right simple technology to manage
all of that right and then also be able
to provide
better care on the point because you
want people to have the support of an
entire health care system their doctors
specialists etc that know when to get
called in
not just waiting until someone has a
serious issue
and goes to the hospital and so we can
predict for example
early stage dementia now with over 90
accuracy because we have people going
into their homes
and tracking weights something is
different than it was the last four
weeks
in the way that they're taking their
medicine or their mood wow and you can
call on the doctor in advance
but but today this system is somebody
shows up at the house
does the two hours leaves fills out a
form five days later
and we have no records in real time to
be able to identify these uh
risk factors if you're listening to this
around around the country aren't you
pissed off you're like you kidding this
guy has this great idea for a service
and he had to roll around the uk
the way the current healthcare system in
the united states is it makes it very
difficult to build
this this type of product it's
frustrating for me too i had to go
through this with my grandpa
unfortunately before he passed
it's so difficult with getting home help
and we were lucky we could afford to
bring someone into the home
here in the us which is insanely
expensive
um and even then like you don't know how
to find someone you can trust
because it's just the one person that's
taking care of them so that you don't
trust them to find every issue
you know you're screwed yeah that's
that's very profound it's true
um you know like you would trust
yourself maybe if you spent all the time
um but then you wouldn't necessarily
entrust the person that you're bringing
in who might not
um be you know as consistent or diligent
or
they they might not be spending the
right amount of time or have the right
expertise
yeah i mean andrew i'm curious from your
perspective you cup you've now seen
my other side of the world on the
entrepreneurial side
and the political world i mean how do
you get
how do we get government and
entrepreneurs
working together more effectively
to solve these issues well i you know i
love what you're trying to do encore
because i think a lot of it
is that entrepreneurs are often
attracted to
areas where they they feel like they're
going to be able to operate
um uh more freely and efficiently
and then if you hit a highly highly
regulated zone then all of a sudden
you're like oh wait and then some
entrepreneurs like you are like willing
to you know
like swim through the muck and figure
out okay like what can i do in one of
these
and sometimes there's a great
opportunity in the highly regulated zone
in part because the regulations have
provided kind of like a mode of
discouragement
like i i worked in healthcare software
in the mid 2000s and i used to start
joking that healthcare is where good
ideas go
to die because because
like a lot of the practices aren't super
rational or efficiency minded and the
measurements are spotty at best
and so you wind up having people adopt
solutions based upon other criteria
um so so that there's there's a massive
opportunity here man i mean what you're
doing is awesome
i think uh on the political side i do
think that
we have to figure out which regulations
uh are holding us back at this point
because
there are a lot of rules that make sense
when you drew them up
and they they had a fine purpose but
then in terms of the impact like
it's a double-edged sword and then we
didn't undo that rule
and then we then made another whole uh
matrix of rules on top of that one that
like spit on top of it then everyone's
looking around
me like that that's pretty much what's
going on but i guess is there a way
that you can like change the culture of
that internally i mean
because some of it's the rules but a lot
of it comes down to the culture of the
people that work
for like you know for the for the
government agencies right where
there isn't necessarily there's a
distrust of the private sector
number one which is probably fairly
warranted given some of the players in
the market today
and then there's also this culture of
fear of trying something new because no
one wants to get fired
so how do you create a culture where the
people who do
implement these policies and these rules
like
want to find ways to work with
innovators and be more innovative as a
government
well so so government bureaucracies have
a number of features
that make sense in their context but do
not necessarily make sense in terms of
pushing the envelope in some of the
issues you're talking about
so uh they're they're highly uh
they're highly regulated themselves uh
they're you know like each
worker tends to have like a whole set of
rules that that are
um constraining what they can and can't
do
they're built for very very long-term
continuity
um and so there are a lot of folks who
who would be better suited frankly to
doing like a certain
uh tour of duty within government i
talked to a guy yesterday who'd like
worked in government for for eight years
and he was a great guy and accomplished
a lot
um but he pretty much said like i did my
tour of duty
you know and i think that that's fair
and but and then but then there are
people that you know the
but the organization generally is built
for like multi-decades-long continuity
and so you have people that
um operate in that time frame and then
if you show up and we're like hey let's
like do it get all the stuff done in 10
months they're like
10 months like i've been here for 10
years and i'm going to be here for 10
years more and so you know
don't necessarily yeah you don't need to
to be that gung-ho
and one organization that does a great
job of this that you know i think
um we can get lessons from is an
organization called code for america
that enlists various people who are
engineers in codingtown and says look
like solve this
government based issue and you know and
then you can return
uh you know to the industry um uh
there's also like the us digital service
that that um does things at the federal
level
uh oh you'd love it so you remember
healthcare.gov
when uh yeah we all remember
so so when when the launch had problems
uh a group of
techies led by a guy named mikey
dickerson from google
came in and uh patched and fixed the
website in real time it was like very
big deal
and then they stuck around to try and
fix other things
web related and tech related and so they
had a workforce
of like the low hundreds
in in dc that they just went around
consulting with uh various agencies
being like hey
like can we like help you with something
we fix things and they ended up with
this like massive
um backlog of projects because everyone
was like we would love your help with
with this thing so and
and they and and it also had a tour of
duty aspect because a lot of them were
techies who would join the us digital
service and then do a tour of duty for
like you know
um three or four years and then uh and
then cycle out
um so there there are things that i'm
optimistic about
i'm going to share an idea with you
encore that i'm going to give it to you
and then maybe you can
do it and it's actually if there's one
human who might be able to do it it
might be you
um as you'll you'll see what i mean in
just a minute so
so so far we've talked about what you're
working on uh in two of the big three
housing and healthcare and they're both
awesome
and so here's something in education
that i've long reflected on
so you know that i spent a number of
years
running what became the country's
largest gmat prep service that helped
get
you know thousands and thousands of
people into various business schools
um and uh and i was looking at that
value proposition it was like wow like a
lot of like why are these people
all heading to business school which is
like a very significant
opportunity cost and career sacrifice
you know it's like two years the tuition
is
uh you know maybe insanely high like a
hundred ten hundred twenty thousand two
hundred thousand dollars
like it's gone up a little bit so yeah
let's call it 200 000. um
and so i made a list of things that
motivate people to go
to get these uh to get their mbas um
and uh one was the credential for sure
uh it was the professional network
the personal network um to to some
extent
um like the book learning but i'm going
to suggest that that stuff's like
you know not that central the
consideration
um to some extent for many people it was
like a career reset or a career switch
it's like you've been working
continuously over periods yeah
the quarter life crisis it's when people
split into banking or something and
burnt down and when i have a quarter
life crisis need a
two year spring two-year spring break
for two hundred thousand dollars
so that so there is a pivot right
there's a career pivot involved
it's like okay i'm in this track and
then i'm gonna um get my mba and there's
gonna be this big career pivot
so then i thought to myself and i said
okay could you provide the credentialing
the professional network the personal
network the career pivot
uh like some of the book learning in a
shorter time frame than two years
uh and uh and so i was imagining
something that i you know like i'd call
it would be like the mckinsey
summer retreat that's like three months
everyone comes together for this period
instead of two years it's three months
but then you you have an environment
where people actually develop real
relationships and friendships
and the thing is about the mckinsey
aspect is that i chose mckinsey because
i was like what's like a very big brand
name
that could actually have the heft that
would would actually be competitive
with like the you know hbs's of the
world or or whatever the programs are
um and so then i thought it's like could
you deliver
like something in like a three month
period at a fraction of the cost that
had a lot of the social elements the
credentialing elements the
networking elements and even like the
employer appeal elements
if you like and then i thought like wow
like what an opportunity that is because
there are all these young people that in
my mind
like are looking for certain things and
the nba is like a very luxe
version of it and very expensive version
of and a very enormous opportunity cost
it's like could you compress it and
deliver
a lot of the benefits i love it listen i
love it i love it
it's uh it's like a much smarter version
of an executive mba
i it makes me reminds me of an idea that
if you decide to ever get out of the
politics thing and come back to the
business world maybe you could start
because this is
something i've been wanting to do and
frankly know the capacity to do right it
was inspired
by a lot of the stuff that you've been
talking about around ai automation
how do we rescale the workforce provide
them with stability right
and so there is some period in this
transition between
automation coming in and people
fully be out of jobs right there'll be a
transition point where it happens
gradually for some sectors
i'm first the problem is today if you
lose your job that is also the point at
which
you need the most amount of financial
help you've just lost your job
and the point where lenders want to do
the least to help you it's this really
bad dynamic right and so and the problem
is as these jobs go away it becomes
harder and harder to ever get back on
your feet
and there's no real clarity on what to
do to get the new skills or what path to
take or what courses whether it's a
summer program like this or if you're
even more vocationally taking a
different type of program to get back in
the workforce
and so i had this thought of what if we
created like an
unemployment lending retraining program
right so you lose your job you actually
depending on your thing
qualify for an emergency set of funds
right and it is priced at a high
interest rate because you are high risk
at that point however
it gives each person who takes that
alone a
clear path towards re-employment that
they can use
they commit part of those funds towards
training and maybe those are provided
for free
every step of the way that they progress
their rates drop so it incentivizes
the de-risking of the loan while
providing people
frankly the clear path to re-employment
so you lose
your job during x we say you know what
here are the five paths that actually
could be
you know most feasible least feasible
etc based on your current skill set
and here are some emergency funds to get
back on your feet and that is an
incentive for you to go kind of
re-qualify and take those courses
um to get rehired there's something here
it's rough
but if anybody could pull it off it's
you i love anything that helps smooth
out these transitions because as you
know like i don't think that
we're doing enough as a society to help
people manage these transitions
and uh you know and like you said the
path is actually very unclear for a lot
of people as to like what that next
opportunity would look like
uh you know a lot of it hinges too upon
um regions
where uh you know the economy's shifting
in a way that sometimes
um the next opportunity for you like
might be a few states away
but right now like you know you don't
recognize that that's the case
[Laughter]
yeah the in in theory the public sector
would be doing more in this direction
and it's something i'm very passionate
about so i can see why you raised it man
um something there yeah no and i like
the way your mind works too because
you're
you're trying to smooth over some of the
financial ups and downs and you're
trying to bring uh
you know like um like trying to try and
front load the value it's like you see
the value that's going to happen when
someone does
get that new job and then you're like
hey let's try and bring it forward to
like where they need it
uh it's a little it's a little bit like
what you're doing with rhino a little
bit
but like i love the way your mind works
um encore
um if someone wants to find out about
your big announcement in june or keep
up with you or find out what's going on
with kairos like what's the best way
they can do so
uh probably the easiest is just
following me on instagram that's where i
try to share some of these things it's
at encore jane
on instagram um you can also go to the
kairos website kairoshq.com
but i'm really excited andrew uh you'll
be one of the first people i call when
we're getting ready to roll this out but
this has been i mean we talk about my
last kind of rant here
about the inequality challenge for our
generation i think
we have only seen the surface of what
inequality can do to our country in a
terrible way
um if we start to feel divided and
when you think about wealth creation for
most
americans the ability to own home equity
is the greatest predictor of kind of
generational wealth
over time that's true and as and as
my generation as millennials and gen z
are living more and more paycheck to
paycheck even if you're living well
right you can work at goldman and look
major to paycheck these days it's
crazy right is as that happens and
people are
less able to buy home equity which is
again
highly levered but in the safest
possible way for
investment assets right
if only the top top top percent of
people are able to buy those homes
over the next 20 years 30 years as that
population
sees their assets compound and the rest
of my generation is just still living
rent check to rent check
there is going to be riots on the street
right more than we've seen in the last
year
and so i'm hopeful that this program
which we have developed i think this is
the first use case i have personally
been a part of which has truly been a
partnership between the government
and us in the private sector to give
every american a path to home ownership
just by paying rent at any apartment
i think this could be a really really
transformative exciting thing well uh
encore i have to applaud
your focus on problems that affect uh
lots of people that that will have a
high impact
if you if you can contribute to solving
for them
i hope more investors and entrepreneurs
follow in your footsteps
you know and i think it it's uh going to
pay off for
a lot of people in more ways than one uh
you know and i just want to congratulate
you on it
oh thanks follow work you're doing too
man thank you
such a pleasure
[Music]
you